[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
إذا تمسكنا جميعًا بحلمنا الأول
، فسيكون العالم مليئًا برعاة البقر
والأميرات ، وظيفتي هي إنشاء
عالم يدوم ساعتين ، وظيفتك
هي إنشاء  عالم يدوم إلى الأبد ،
فأنت مبتكرو المستقبل
، القادة والقائمون على رعايتك ، أحيانًا ستضربك الحياة
في رأسك بحجر
لا تفقد الثقة ، أنا مقتنع
بأن الشيء الوحيد الذي جعلني أستمر هو أنني
أحببت ما فعلته  يجب أن تجد ما
تحبه إذا كنت سأقع ، لا
أريد أن أعود إلى أي شيء باستثناء
إيماني ، أريد أن أتراجع إلى الأمام ،
لقد أجرى توماس إديسون كينتوك ألف
تجربة فاشلة هل تعلم أنني لم أكن
أعرف  ذلك لأن
المصباح الألف والأول كان يسقط للأمام ،
أراد ديفيد ليترمان أن يكون جوني
كارسون ولم يكن كذلك ، ونتيجة لذلك ،
أراد جيلي من الكوميديين أن يكون
ديفيد ليترمان ولم يكن أي منا من
أقراني وقد فاتني جميعًا هذه العلامة
بألف طريقة مختلفة ولكن  النقطة
هي أن هذا هو فشلنا في أن نصبح مثالنا
المتصور الذي يحددنا في النهاية
ويجعلنا فريدًا من نوعه ، من الواضح أن المسار الذي
اخترته لن
يناسبك لشخص لست مضحكا للغاية ،
فكيف تعرف ما هو الطريق الصحيح
لاختيار النتيجة التي تريدها
والإجابة الصادقة هي أنك لن
تحب ما
تجيده ، فالكفاءة سلعة نادرة في هذا
اليوم وهذا العصر
لم أسأل كثيرًا عما إذا كنت أتخيل يومًا ما عندما كنت
طفلاً  كوني عضوًا في المحكمة العليا
في أعلى محكمة في الولايات المتحدة ،
لا أقول عندما كنت طفلاً ،
كانت عائلتي فقيرة ولا يوجد محامٍ أو قضاة يعيشون في الحي الذي أعيش فيه ،
لا يمكنك أن تحلم
بأن تصبح شيئًا لا تعرفه
عنك ، عليك أن تتعلم كيف تحلم  كل
قرار صائب اتخذته جاء
من حدسي وكل قرار خاطئ اتخذته
كان نتيجة عدم الاستماع إلى
صوتي الأعظم إذا لم أشعر أنه ليس على ما
يرام ، فلا أفعل ذلك هذا هو الدرس
[موسيقى]